الفن في حفله تتويج اختيارات استثنائيه
تعكس الحس الفني للملك مزيج موسيقي جمع
بين شمال افريقيا وايرلندا في حفل تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث في بريطانيا قدمه
الملحن الجزائري طارق اوريجان الطريقه
الذي كان احد خيارات الملك شارك في حفل
تنصيب الملك بمقطوعته
الموسيقيه تدمج تاثير الكتابه الصوتيه في
عصر النهضه والموسيقى في شمال افريقيا
ومجموعات الروك البريطانيه في الستينيات
والسبعينيات وايضا موسيقى الجاز يصف مختص
الفن موسيقى طارق بانها حساسه ورائعه
لنستمع الان الى جزء من المقطوعه المشاركه
في حفل التتويج التاريخي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات